[Musique]
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
joueurs de soccer Pelé à passer près de
20 ans sur les terrains à éblouir le
public il est devenu le buteur le plus
prolifique de son sport jouant avec le
cube brésilien Santos et l'équipe
nationale du Brésil puis les remporté
trois Coupes du monde et a porté le
Brésil vers les sommets ces mouvements
fascinants ont subjugués des joueurs et
les amateurs son style rapide et fluide
relayé par la télévision en noir et
blanc puis en couleur à révolutionné le
soccer il est devenu ensuite un
ambassadeur mondial de son sport depuis
la confirmation de sa disparition la
planète soccer lui rend hommage on voit
dans la ville de Santos au pellet a
passé la plupart de sa carrière
des milliers de fans qui affluent vers
le stade via la bomiro le stade de
l'équipe de Santos dans une sorte de
pèlerinage pour rendre hommage au roi du
football je pense que ça a été une des
premières icônes justement du monde du
football la personne sur qui on mettait
l'image au début des années 60 vous
allez apparaissait au Brésil aussi donc
c'est celui qui a incarné le star system
au niveau du football mondial sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il y a ne M'Bappé
héros de l'équipe de France finaliste de
la récente Coupe du Monde a salué le
départ du roi dont l'héritage ne sera
jamais oublié Lionel Messi et Cristiano
Ronaldo font part de leur tristesse il a
été une inspiration pour tant de gens
une référence d'hier d'aujourd'hui pour
toujours écrire Ronaldo le club espagnol
FC Barcelone affirme que Pelé un des
plus grands a fait du soccer un sport
plus grand que nature le sprinterusain
Bolt salut une légende du sport tandis
que la fédération brésilienne de soccer
rappelle qu'il est éternel on a
l'impression que sa légende grandit
encore aujourd'hui au vu de toutes les
images qu'il a pu nous partager de tous
les dribbles qu'il a inventé c'est
vraiment vraiment une triste nouvelle et
un grand grand joueur qui disparaît
aujourd'hui
Philippe répond Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]